مخاطر التطبيق الصيني لا تقتصروا على
الامن المعلوماتيه فحسب بل هناك ما هو
اخطر صحه الاطفال والمراهقين
خوارزميات تيك توك احدى اهم عوامل نجاحه
واليوم احدى اهم النقاط التي يستخدمها
منتقد التطبيق الصيني تعرض محتوى تعرض
محتوى مشابها للمستخدمين المستخدمين في كل
مره يزورون فيها المنصه بحيث يتم تخصيص
محتوى محدد لهم بالمعنى الحرفي يتشاركونه
مع نظرائهم من اصحاب الاهتمام المشترك على
سبيل المثال وبحسب مركز مكافحه الكراهيه
الرقميه تم انشاء حسابات وهميه لاطفال في
السن 13 عاما شاهدت الحسابات مقطع فيديو
عن فقدان الوزن او معاناه شخص من زياده
الوزن فما لبث تيك توك ان اقترح عليه
مقاطع فيديو لصوره الجسد والصحه العقليه
امر يحدث كل 93 ثانيه ولهذا يتهم البعض
التيك توك بالمسؤوليه عن تعرض الكثير من
الاطفال والمراهقين الاضطرابات في الاكل
والاكتئاب واحيانا الانتحار فما هو رد
التطبيق
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات